I think once you understand the flows of
wealth you can see that our middle class
will shrink living standards will shrink
and the economy will continue to fail
and this is the realization I had back
in 2011.
um and it was also the realization I had
in 2020 when covet happened
because you could see that the wealthy
were going to get massively more rich
if you know the way that the rich
Behavior will know they will use that
money to buy assets from the middle
class that will increase inequality more
and that will lead this spiral to
accelerate so when you look at the whole
picture
what you can see is that that the
situation is
basically phenomenally Bleak because if
in the absence of any action being taken
it has become inevitable that
ordinary families and the existing
middle class will over time lose all of
their assets and that will happen
generationally so it'll be difficult for
you to see it as an individual but if
you can pay yourself to your parents and
your kids and your grandkids you will
see each generation getting poorer over
time